hey guys i'm ryan right and i'm madison
baby madison is here today she came on
the channel forever ago kiss you guys
are known Madison she is an actress who
has appeared in such works as the master
by Paul Thomas Anderson and she's also
has a reoccurring role on the Fosters
and you could catch her in outlaws and
angels that she just finished filming
starring Chad Michael Murray
why aren't you my publicist I don't know
that down know how that damn a tional
Ryan thank you thank you so much anyway
yeah she's a working actress speaking of
actors and [ __ ] 10 amazing improvised
movie moments by Screen Rant and that's
what we do we're improvising all this
right now oh we're improvising I'll just
right now unscripted
but he Fletcher will be on there Jago
and Shayne seen been everywhere just how
about money and energies and creating
the next Hollywood hit before the
cameras even start rolling but as
polished or acclaimed as a script maybe
there's no predicting what will happen
once the cast and crew arrive on set and
sometimes lines or scenes improvised on
the spot can not only work but become
instant classics here are screen rants
10 amazing improvised movie moments
Harry Potter the Chamber of Secrets the
cast of the Harry Potter series faced
pressures not many actors will ever
experience
imagine being trusted to play beloved
characters in eight movies over the span
of a decade but even at a young age they
proved to be a talented group
when Lucius Malfoy arrives at the end of
the second movie to proclaim his
innocence there was no line in the
script to end a conversation actor Jason
Isaacs asked for advice and the director
told him to just make something up
Malfoy turned to the boy wizard
sarcastically hoping he would keep
saving the day mr. Potter will always be
around to save the day and the 12 year
old Daniel Radcliffe didn't disappoint
reacting to the veiled threat with the
promise of his own don't worry I will be
no way those infers all better dr.
Radcliffe was the real deal fast and
furious 6 The Fast & Furious movie
series owes as much of its success to
the memorable cast as the high-speed
action the love-hate relationship
between characters played by Ludacris
bridges and Tyrese Gibson is one fan
favorite dynamic if since forehead is a
regular target for teasing nah that's
not as big as your forehead and he can
give as good as he gets
taking a playful shot at Dwayne the rock
Johnson at the end of the sixth move
better hide your baby or better hide
that big-ass forehead Reese's baby oil
line was scripted but The Rock's reply
wasn't meaning both of his co-stars
reactions were caught in real-time
content Marty Scorsese story of an oh
yeah holding to a Boston crime family
was overflowing with talented actors
Jack Nicholson and Leonardo DiCaprio
shared a handful of incredible seats
when Nicholson's mob boss suspects he
has a rat in his crew the young recruit
talks tough to draw off suspicion but
Nicholson decided to add something to
the scene without informing his co-star
pulling a gun out from under the table
changes the tone of the scene entirely
and it visibly rattled DiCaprio a
stating character though and use the
added emotion to deliver an even better
version that well done the finished
fiction to [ __ ] you the Lord of the
Rings the Fellowship of the Ring my lord
of the Rings and it was a massive war
but in the trilogy's first film a fight
between Strider and an youkai leader was
thrilling enough although it was a lot
more dangerous than audiences realized
during the fight the orc actor was
supposed to throw a stunt knife past
Viggo Mortensen who would dodge out of
the way when the see was filmed knife
slipped
flying directly at Mortensen's face the
actors weapons training took over he
instantly reacted by knocking the blade
out of the air no no since the mistake
was too good to leave out of the final
cut
diehard Marla very willis relied on
practical effects in a single skyscraper
to make diehard one of the greatest
action movies ever made no fan will
forget the death of the villain Hans
Gruber who realised this plan was blown
only as he dropped 30 stories off the
building's edge the effects have stood
the test of time but its actor Alan
Rickman's expression that sold the
moments what most don't know is that it
wasn't really acting when Rickman was
suspended for the real green screen drop
the director dropped him prematurely to
guarantee the surprised look would be
genuine the actor wasn't impressed but
you can't argue with the results
ah Marvis first money starring gas
garden bartender showed a lighter side
to super heroics but when Thor and Loki
shared scenes with their father Odin the
result was pretty Shakespearean that was
mostly due to the classical training of
Tom Hiddleston and Anthony Hopkins but
their emotions boiling over in one
memorable moment when Odin decides to
banish store from his home lo he comes
to his defense but is silenced by a
menacing growl from his typically
composed father
apparently the reply wasn't scripted
Hopkins simply snarled and character and
Hilson's stunned reaction also in
character is just as improvised bhajan
story of Bilbo Baggins greatest
adventure begins as any Hobbit tale [ __ ]
with the party the door to storm bill
goes kitchen clearly know how to have
fun but not all their stunts and tricks
are fueled by CG while shooting the
scene the cast decided to throw a
hard-boiled egg the length of the dinner
table into actor Stephen Hunter's mouth
haha audiences see in the finished film
is the very first take what the actors
just as thrilled in surprise to see it
pulled off so perfectly Star Trek the
original Star Trek TV series made James
Kirk Spock Leonard Nimoy and the crew of
the USS Enterprise household names which
meant millions of fans who were less
than happy to see the roles recast for
the 2009 movie reboot Karl Urban landed
the role of doctor McCoy but older
viewers knew the character better by his
nickname bones the name was a play on
the term saw bones but urban decided to
add his own spin the new McCoy still
split with his wife before joining
forces with Jim Kirk but when it came
time to shoot their introduction Irvin
improvised a new explanation for his
future nickname left bones obviously
Abrams was a fan the two times directors
don't insist on repeating takes just to
make sure they have a wealth of choices
and editing sometimes it's to help their
actors warm up and execute a scene with
added emotion in the middle chapter of
Peter Jackson's Lord of the Rings
trilogy
Aragorn arrives to find what he believes
are the burned remains of his Hobbit
friends kicking an orc helmet and anger
and defeat with each take after Viggo
Mortensen knocked the helmet closer and
closer to the camera so Jackson kept
resetting until Martinson let out a
gut-wrenching scream before falling to
his knees
Jackson was impressed but it turned out
the added emotion was due to the broken
toes the actor suffered on the same wine
included in the finished fatty Fight
Club
once Tyler Durden steps out for the mind
of fight clubs narrator and into his
real life he forces the high-strung
zombie to express himself in an unusual
way when it came to shooting the scene
director David Fincher felt something
more was needed telling actor Ed Norton
not to punch Brad Pitt in the shoulder
as they planned but to go for his ear
not even getting him away I want you to
hit me as hard as you can
the decision paid off with Pitts
reaction making it into the final movie
as a fan favorite moment mother [ __ ]
that's right you're in curious ka year
so what do you think of our list any
miss any of your favorite unscripted
scenes or dialogue let us know in our
comment section and don't forget to
subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one
Wow that's a lot that's a lot what's
amazing about that list is a lot of
these moments are like impactful moments
in the film itself and not like just
like any film like they could have put
movies that are not as big like those
are all like classic yeah
oh yeah the Harry Potter the German that
how oh god I liked the way that was shot
it just that shocked me that that was
actually improvised I took it as a total
scripted moment because it seems so like
Hollywood powerful up at 9:00 okay and
it's cool that like Daniel Radcliffe as
a young lad was able to cool up pull off
wine - they're very talented very Jones
that's a lot to carry as a young person
oh yeah
gosh he's probably got a huge dick now
that's what comes with success right
telly
I noticed the more subs I get the bigger
my penis gets wonder I wonder how you
would explain that are you sure it's not
your ego I've never achieved a full
erection before so I'm learning to
develop an erection with more subs this
is something we should definitely talk
about we should maybe an another time
but it's something that maybe another
time the cameras on the departed the
departed that scene I did hear about
that one Jack Nicholson pulls out a gun
and how that was improvised okay I I
just did a movie where we work with guns
and it is very scary they have it they
have a gun check before you go and you
make sure that all the chambers are
empty
if you don't know if the guns [ __ ]
taking care of people and item I knew
the gun was taken care of and I was
scared out of my mind I can like his
reaction is so real because they could
show you that it's fine and then when
you have a gun on set it's just oh my
gosh
the Jack Nicholson's know it to
improvise great stuff like that you know
and it's cool he's willing to do that to
help out the other actors like the only
people that could get away with that Oh
totally yeah
can you imagine if I was on the set and
I just pulled out a gun in the scene
what are you doing if you did that on
the Fosters it would make one sense
make sure these gates mention
button would it make sense maybe young
Daisy has I don't think the subscriber
base knows enough about the Fosters to
catch on the Lord of the Rings when they
threw the knife at Viggo Mortensen and
and he he was able to hit it can you
imagine though that was no wait it's
like that that's what you're worried
about the gun like actual knife I know
in the fact of how he saw it coming
towards him and he was able to knock it
away like what what about what a badass
so [ __ ] impress us but I'm sure he
was pissed
and that moment always stood out to me
cuz I'm always like I should throw a
real knife that's what I want to know I
don't know he was probably in character
as the orc okay that's how I'll justify
it really intense method acting he's
probably really just a [ __ ] idiot
like behind the scenes stuff you see how
to sing better and it went south he is
racist there's a lot of character study
there's too much character study in Thor
when Loki is this is like Father and
then Anthony Hopkins just goes right
like what like what the heck father and
then at the opposite yeah that moment I
always thought was kind of silly cuz I
thought he was actually saying a word
and I was like oh I just don't
understand what he's saying
now that I find him it's a grunt I mean
I had just to scream for stuff out of
fear on sets and it's always very
awkward because you don't know how
you're gonna scream and then when you're
forcing it it's just weird
well he's heartbroken in that moment you
know he has to banish his son to another
planet or to teach him a lesson maybe
he's just a douche bag yeah that's also
the other interpretation being banished
from your your planet well that's a lot
of stress to handle as it as a human
being or whatever you know superhero
what I grew up knowing was if you're not
a good person on earth you get banished
to hell forever I like a good believing
yeah this is like barren and when I talk
about defining moments call it like Star
Trek characters are such a classic
character all them and then this guy who
has a nickname of bones has a very
specific backstory
then he changes it in the moment and
they actually go however you have it
you've never seen Star Trek I'm feeling
failing it life that is what I wanted to
tell you before the camera started
rolling
oh so it's actually good that you Amy
edited yourself to talk about yeah you
are a failure you um have a lot more
success than me going right now some
never mind
wait I thought I thought your day was
getting bigger please you know there's a
lie
and then viggo mortensen again when he
like kick the helmet and broke his toes
and then he lets out that yell and I
remember watching that moment as an
actor oh continue going and midst an
injury but it's so funny how the
improvised moment is another a moments
in the dark night that are improvised I
know Full Metal Jacket the drill
sergeant improvised almost everything
you said wasn't like the adrenaline you
get as an actor it's easier to come
across more authentic in an improvised
moment and if you know how to improvise
I think because you're not thinking
about the words you got to just be and
speak you know yeah so I can see why a
lot of actor while I directors are
actually okay with improv because it
gets you to behave like the camera so
accidental I did my think my favorite
improvising moment that happened was I
was working on a movie where I'm an evil
ghost okay something called Jimmy Marx
is dead okay um and me and my co-star
Cameron Monaghan we're doing this scene
where like I'm hunting him down
this evil ghost I won't give it away but
he goes into his bedroom and shuts the
door and I come and I'm banging on the
bedroom door and it was on him it was
banging on the door so it looked like
someone was actually trying to bust in
and like I don't look that strong so I
was like throwing my body in to the door
and the door wires started to break and
it literally there was a hole and I
climbed through the hole and so when you
watch the movie my friend Cameron is
like terrified out of his mind probably
thinking you how did she break down the
door is that a metaphor for your
relationships
Oh God
why are you so funny dude everyday
you're just like why am I so funny
usually and why am I so good-looking and
why is my penis so small so yeah keep
changing what you're saying that's the
true one truth you're wondering no
wonder why are you twisting why does she
twist it
hey guys um as we were saying if you do
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects we should totally do yes
yes Thank You Madison and for Madison
little wonderful working beautifully
talented actress she is on a lot of
social networks at Madison Beatty
Facebook Instagram Twitter all of it
from there and I have Facebook Instagram
Twitter - she has a few more followers
than me a few thousand more followers
than me a few 10,000 more followers I
follow you I that means nothing to me